all right hey this is Pete peppers from
candy crush soda saga tips and this is a
walkthrough for level 110 we got a
couple people asking about this in the
group so I'm going to play through and
talk about some of the decisions the
main thing in the beginning is you just
want to break through the top layers of
honey wherever you can
by making specials you know it's pretty
straightforward there's not a lot of
choices because there's not a lot of
space so ideally you know going down
through the middle is fine like I'm
doing right now but you can go down the
side too if you need to just know
wherever you can clear out some space
and do some damage to the chocolate so
that it won't keep growing so there you
can see I would make a little match on
the side fold it back
check over the middle for specials and
then just keep working my way down my my
general plan on a board like this is to
try to hit the chocolate you know on
every other match or something when I
can right here I don't really have it
but I can set this off and that'll open
up the whole middle and I'll get some
pieces to drop through so strike tier is
good because we can shoot it down and
clear off the the licorice and a good
really good combo that was another case
where I you know wanted to hit the
chocolate another good thing you want to
start looking for at this point is what
I just made which is a horizontal with
the fish that one really didn't go where
I wanted it to but I want to keep doing
that it hopes of getting one in the
bottom row that can really speed things
along for you
and that might have been a little bit of
a mistake but I think here I want to
match the two stripes above the column
that has the most chocolate in it and
then that'll open things up I mean
that's why I said I think I made a
mistake there I could have made a fish
instead but that's alright we're moving
pretty good
we have seven moves left here I want to
look for a color bomb if I can make one
so I'll move this one down and make that
and I'm a little bit stuck I can't
really think here side off the wrapped
so that'll break out a little bit more
room and the color bomb we want to use
but if there's not a good reason to then
I think we can just leave it there for
now if it goes off then it'll be fine
cuz it'll hit something but right here I
think the best move is to drop this blue
in the middle and hit the chocolate
again and now we have a whole wide open
Center so what I'm looking for is like a
make a fish that I can match with the
color bomb or make a stripe that I can
match with the color bomb and now stuff
we have to really think because we only
have 11 moves left and they're gonna go
fast and we want to try to create some
damage whenever possible and think here
maybe the red need maybe hit the
chocolate again because it'll it'll
spread on every move that we don't hit
it I could go for a color bomb here
again see if I get lucky I got the
orange one in place but I can't drop it
so yeah I'll hit the hit that over there
get some things to come down and now I
can make another color bomb so this
color bomb it might be better or just to
use it like maybe on the green here I
have a green one because that will take
out a lot of chocolate and clear out the
space at the bottom too so maybe I'll be
able to get a better
combo and we are down to the wire so I
want to hit the chocolate here the color
bombs not gonna do much so I'm gonna
ignore that if I match the blue up here
on the left that's gonna set up that'll
set up a rap candy which I'm I might be
able to use but there's also a chance
that I can maybe set up one more yeah
now look I can I can make this and
that's gonna drop and I'll be able to
set up the coloring candy in the middle
and hopefully match it with this fish
it's alright good so now I can match
this you want to bring the top one down
you only have to move so it's gonna sit
right next to the fish and now this
should come pretty close one thing
that's good about matching colouring
canes with finished rather than colored
bombs with fish as they come in two
waves like that did and that was enough
to finish it off when I say two waves I
mean it'll be it released one one round
for the one color and then another round
so you get even though some of those
chocolates still had the licorice on it
and ate the licorice and the chocolate
at the same time so that's that's how
you do it I mean this is the level you
know you're not going to be able to do
it every time it's usually gonna come
down to the last couple moves it's
pretty rare to get you know really good
board where you get done with like a ton
of moves left over so don't give up like
you saw there I had quite a bit of
chocolate left on the fourth but with
that extra space I opened up I had room
to make specials and then it's just a
matter of making the best descriptive
decisions and you are going to need to
plan it out I mean there's no super
strategy you know like trick to it so it
all comes down to planning at the end
get to those last moves so I hope this
helps please like the video share it
subscribe to our channel so you can find
more commentary videos we come out with
them all the time and we'll be on more
soon thanks